all right let's jump into this first
story yo this story is wild Texas
National Guard deploys armed soldiers to
block Biden's border patrol access to
the river in Eagle Pass Governor Abbott
is not harming border patrol operations
he is enhancing them that's what they
say on Thursday night the Texas National
Guard took control of Shelby Park in the
city of Eagle Pass Texas which has been
at the center of President Joe Biden's
illegal immigrant crisis at the US
Southern border according to the Dallas
Morning News the state government has
seized control of the area and the Texas
National Guard has set up razor wire and
fences to block off the park a filing
from Biden's Department of Justice
reveals the Texas National Guard has
blocked points of entry and has deployed
armed soldiers and vehicles to block
border patrol Agents from access to the
river by bypassing through ENT bypassing
through entry points in the federal
border barrier Eagle Pass mayor Rolando
Selenas told reporters that the decision
was made as part of the Republican
Governor Greg Abbott's emergency
declaration and was not something the
city had requested he added that as a
result the Border Patrol was not
operating in the area Okay so this this
is exactly what I said I was worried
about weeks ago when we're looking at
the Biden Administration CBP
facilitating illegal immigration into
this country when you have videos of
these these uh it's the construction
equipment lifting up the razor wire that
was placed there by the state to protect
the state you've got the federal
government facilitating crimes and
unconstitutional outright it's
unconstitutional for them not to defend
the States from Invasion but they're
actually facilitating the illegal
immigration outright and then when Greg
Abbott says this is illegal the doj sues
them my fear was exactly this and what
comes next terrifies me what happens
when the Texas National Guard is
deployed with rifles with weapons to
defend the state and uphold its laws and
the Biden Administration Federal
Allegiance say you are you're the ones
committing the crimes both groups point
at each other saying you're committing
crimes for now I'm hoping what happens
the porder patrol leaves they just leave
they can file their lawsuits and that's
the end of it but my fear is that we get
to the point where Tex Texas National
Guard has ordered secure this area do
not let people pass plane closed federal
agent with a gun walks up and says lower
your weapon Federal this is a federal
border jurisdiction the state says back
the F off don't move and things escalate
from there I think because it's a
situation where everyone on both sides
are trying to preserve life you've got
the federal government saying these poor
immigrants we need to preserve their
lives the whereas the Texas government
saying we need to preserve the lives of
our citizens that the the law
enforcement is not going to turn on they
they both want to like deescalate and
make this as I I got I got I got to stop
you right there and we'll do a fact
check the Biden Administration I believe
although it is an opinion statement I'll
respect that I will but I do think it is
fair to say the Biden Administration is
not trying to save lives yeah people
people coming on this journey die young
women are are horribly raped in huge
numbers and crossing the river is
dangerous they die children are getting
trafficked and raped they're finding
5-year-old girls with 10 samples of seen
inside of them I mean it's terrible
that's not really a pro-life position to
take no and they're they're dying in the
desert yeah so if the Biden administra
actually said we're going to protect
these people he would go to the meican
government saying we're securing our
borders we're locking it down and you
need to stop these people before they
cross into this dangerous territory
that's the argument I would make
personally I don't think that they're
helping by letting them urging them to
come across the border but I think the
state of mind that they have is toxic
compassion we can help everyone come
every you know I think that's an
excessively uh optimistic perspective on
what the Biden Administration is there
for if you look at the the EU policy if
you look at the American policy over the
past 20 30 years but really aggressively
so as of late uh it seems quite clear to
me that this is actually a a plan to
flood the country with immigrants and as
a Libertarian I'm I'm rarely am I
considered a border Hawk but when you
actually look at it and you see that
this is like a a an operation that's
being ran on high I think that it would
be foolish to look the other way and say
oh no they're just people looking for
opportunity if if it were if it were the
case as it was historically that if you
were an immigrant that got across the
border and the only thing offered to you
was perhaps a low-level job and you had
to grind your way to the top that's a
totally different incentive structure
than what we face today where these
people are offered clothes and food and
housing and everything that they could
and sex changes and health and
Healthcare I mean the list goes on and
on uh I don't think that this is an
accident and I don't think it has
anything to do with uh sympathy for
would all S I was just going to say I
don't think that we can Overlook the
fact that this is being done in an
election year as well because what's
happening is you're having an invasion
okay they're trying to replace the
population the the great replacement is
not some conspiracy theory like the
left-wing media wants it to be they say
that it's some kind of white supremacist
conspiracy theory and as we know it's
very real we are being replaced in this
country by Third World Invaders criminal
illegal alien Invaders and unfortunately
what's happening is when these illegals
are coming to places like Texas you have
Governors like Governor Abbott who are
then putting them on buses and I I had
um you know one of my uh followers on X
sent me a video that they filmed of a
bus of these illegals with Texas plates
getting dropped off at a uh train
station just outside of Chicago why does
that matter well people may think oh
it's all fun and games you know hahaa
give these Democrats a taste of their
own medicine by shipping them to
Sanctuary cities but these are cities
where they give illegals driver licenses
and so these people are going to have
IDs and what's going to stop them not
that we really have voter ID in this
country anyway but uh what's going to
stop these people from voting in our
election but that's not the issue vote
I'm I'm not I'm not concerned in the
immediate with the idea that illegal
immigrant votes the issue is simply by
being here it gives Democrats more
congressional seats and more electoral
votes so that has to do with the
elections but so it's it's it's that's
my point is that they're doing it on
purpose and we saw the Democrat from New
York I don't know her name who said that
she's in favor of this because it's
going to you know create more of these
districts there's that school in I think
it was in New York where they said all
the students have to stay home and and
and do remote learning because they're
bringing the illegal immigrants into
that school someone posted the uh uh
political a political map of the area
and found that this area of this of of
the city or or this area of New York
voted Republican and the surrounding
area is Democrat so sure enough the area
targeted where they're shipping in a
bunch of these migrants is a red area
but what happens with illegal immigrants
in the immediate it is true that when
these people come in and then I'm
willing to bet that Joe Biden rubber
stamps some kind of amnesty executive
order unconstitutional
and then makes everyone fight about it
in the Supreme Court for years but when
he does that you may actually then see a
quick turnaround illegal immigrants
voting you will definitely see their
children voting they're very likely to
vote Democrat because they want the
benefits to themselves and their
families but in the immediate when they
count population in the census they will
say oh look 10 million people live here
now that's that's going to be I mean
what are we looking at 12 congressional
seats and 12 electoral votes for this
state but these people aren't even
citizens but they're getting Federal
representation that and that's what we
are are we're not a democracy it doesn't
matter if the single individual votes if
you have 10 Democrats living in an area
and they put 750,000 illegal IM
immigrants in it those 10 American
citizens now get one Democrat to
represent them in Congress and that's
why it's so important that we get
president Trump back in office because
president Trump has said that he's in
favor of banning Birthright citizenship
and in fact every single GOP candidate
so far including V ramas swame has said
that they're in favor of banning
Birthright citizenship which is what
happens of course when these anchor
babies are born and there's only one
candidate that won't agree to it and
it's Nikki Haley because she would then
be disqualified from running for office
because she herself is an anchor baby I
don't know if you knew that Tim but
Nikki Haley's parents were not uh
citizens they were both immigrants who
had only been in this country for uh
less than three years at the time of her
birth uh which means that she
technically is not a natural-born
citizen which is a requirement to run
for president and so that's why we need
to elect a president president Donald
Trump every single candidate who wants
to be president going forward whether
whether it be 2024 2028 or onward needs
to commit to Banning Birthright
citizenship we cannot be giving favors
out to Anchor babies I I think I think
this an interesting way to look at it is
I think the argument Donald Trump has as
well as VI ramaswami is the founding
fathers did not intend for this idea of
Birthright citizenship this idea that
simply because you were born here you
are now entitled to the full benefits of
the public coffers and the National
Defense etc etc the 14th amendment was
trying to rectify the issue of slavery
basically saying these people here their
citizens
and it turned into something that almost
no other country on the planet does I
think there's like one or two you can
come here illegally have a kid and that
kid's a citizen no one in the world does
that so reasonably I don't think the
issue is that we're Banning it I think
we got to we got to reframe it enforcing
the existing standards of the
Constitution as to what it means to be a
citizen yeah if if we you know this is
the game that that Democrats are really
good at playing is reframing the
narrative that we are the ones who want
to take action when in fact they already
took the action in the in the first
place in their interpretation of how you
get to be a citizen it' be cool if you
could become a citizen by the time you
turn 18 as a kid just by taking tests
and things throughout your your course
of life because you could easily educate
someone from another country from
parents that were illegal to be better
citizens better knowledgeable equipped
people than some people that just lounge
around and drink Mountain Dew all the
time yes I think it's important to
address that right you've got leftists
who were born in this country let's say
they're fifth or sixth generation
American and they hate this country and
want to see it burnt to the ground and
then you have people desperately trying
to come to this country because they
believe in the American dream the only
problem if you're going to commit a
crime to enter this country I I don't
think you're the kind of person that
really does believe in this country
breaking the law to come here is the
kind of it's you know if someone comes
and knocks on your door and says I'd
like to apply to be a roommate in this
building I think it's a really great
house and I can pay my rent you say okay
I believe you if someone breaks in your
house you're like I don't trust this
person actually cares about what's going
on here I think we're past the time
though of the discussion about whether
whether it's legal or illegal I think we
need a full immigration moratorium we we
are at full capacity here in this
country right now and I don't think that
given you know record high inflation uh
the disaster known as biomics our wide
open border we don't need anyone else
coming into this country this is what I
advocated when and I ran on as a
candidate for congress when I ran in
Florida as well I think that we need a
10-year minimum probably a 20-year
minimum really we're being honest when
we look at the actual number of illegals
in this country immigration moratorium I
think we need to haul immigration Al
together I'm I'm I'm GNA I'm I'm I'm
going have to counter that Laura and say
we actually need the inversion and we
need to mass Deport I'm I'm kidding I'm
in favor of both I want mass
deportations and an immigration
moratorium we're already dealing with a
a population decline if you if you were
to do that I think that you'd have to
address the the fiscal concerns and just
from a purely pragmatic uh assessment I
agree with you that that we can't afford
all of these people we certainly have
room not in the cities but there's room
in this country it's not like we have
nothing but cities everywhere the the
real issue is that from the year 2000
the national debt was just had just
broken $5 trillion as of today it sits
at 34 trillion that's that's over six
times multiplier in less than 25 years
if you if you look at the interest on
the national debt it will uh be about
150% this year of what we spend on our
National Defense our National Defense
is comparable to the 10 biggest
countries in the world combined I mean
we're talking enormous sums of money so
if we're not going to get our financial
house in order then we absolutely have
to keep the the in the influx of MiG but
that's one way that we can get our
financial house in order I mean just
Luke mentioned this earlier right
they're giving sex changes now and
health care to illegal aliens the price
tag to provide free health care and just
free healthcare to illegal aliens not to
mention the cost of illegal uh illegal
immigration and this invasion in our
country as it stands right so if we want
to start reducing our debt and also
start being more fiscally responsible
and fiscally conservative then that's
exactly what we need we need to
militarize the United States border as
you were referencing in the beginning of
the of of the show uh we need mass
deportations and we need an immigration
moratorium I mean it's a slap in the
face to all Americans who I pay over I
mean there was a point in time I was
paying over $500 a month for healthcare
and so what just you get to come across
this country why not just anounce your
United States citizenship and cross over
from Mexico illegally and then get a
free cell phone and new clothes and free
healthcare and a sexchange thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net